okay so mortal kombat is one of the best
video game movies ever made
it fully realizes several things about
the almost 30 year old franchise
and is packed with some amazing easter
eggs hidden details and things you
missed
first launched all the way back in 1992
creators ed boone and john tobias were
brainstorming what to call the game
and decided that instead of spelling
combat with a c that they would change
it to a k
in order to be able to trademark the
term main character carl jung
actually remarks on this during the
movie by doing what many fans did at the
time
and pointing out that it's spelled wrong
the creator's names also pop up in the
movie itself
when jax remarks that cole took the belt
from eddie tobias
which is of course a combo of theirs
cole is a descendant of the great ninja
hanzo hazashi
who we see being murdered in the opening
of the movie
hanzo or rather scorpion typically dons
the colours black and yellow
and the lineage between the pair is
hinted at by the fact that cole
constantly wears these colors too
his bag strap is black with a yellow
handle on it and even the bracelet that
his daughter gives him
shares this color scheme showing how
it's all connected
now the murder of hanzo is very similar
to how it plays out in the animated film
mortal kombat scorpions revenge however
the scene does change several things up
and in the games the hit was ordered by
quan chi this was done so that the
villain could gain a powerful member of
his forces in the nether realm and
whereas typically
it was just business here it's rather
personal
now what the opening does beautifully is
that it sets up the rivalry between
behan and hanzo
that ultimately pushes most of the plot
forward in the film
scorpion gets his revenge at the end of
the movie by pulling off his classic
fire breathing fatality
and this has appeared in several of the
games we can see that his mouth
transforms into a skull
and when the character returns to the
nether realm you can also slightly make
out his more demonic appearance
which too is a nod to the source
material now though this feud lasted for
centuries
hanzo could have actually killed bihan
much earlier in the movie
by using the buckets that he had at his
home in the original film
liu kang defeated sub-zero by doing the
ice bucket challenge on him
as he charged an attack however hanzo
decided to leave them behind
which is of course why he lost probably
not what he lost it's a it's a reach
i'll admit
now though it seems like be han began so
sorry that was bad
in the game franchise he actually comes
back as a character
called noob cybot when discussing the
antagonist the creative team
actually remarked that sub-zero done's
dark clothes rather than like blue he
typically has
because they wanted to foreshadow this
transformation now his storyline also
seems to be based on the character eron
black
who was hired by shang tsung to
assassinate challengers in mortal kombat
x
he goes after cole who is saved by jax
but after
sub-zero disarms him and leaves him with
a cold
shoulder he has to fend for himself i
know i did that pun last video but come
on yeah that that's a cold pun
a jack's pun and a sub-zero one the like
button's right there
now during the movie we see him pull off
his fatality from the game
which is where he claps his hands
together to crush someone's head
this has been present in several of the
titles after first showing up in mortal
kombat 2.
during jax's journey through the
abandoned building we can actually see
graffiti on the wall that says
downright lp which is how you pull off
sub-zero's ice attack on the arcade
cabinet
cole travels to sonia blade's house and
here we see a newspaper article for
nightwolf
a character that you might know from
mortal kombat annihilation
and the third game onwards amongst the
clippings is a vars with a centaur on it
which could be a nod to the character
mataro there's also a cracked skull
which looks like one of the x-ray
attacks from the games we can also catch
the character ko
khan who took over our world after shao
khan's death
the character is actually riffing on the
mayan god of war bulak chaptan
hence why he's introduced here it's at
this point that we meekeno
who we learned throughout the film has
the arcana of carrying this entire movie
on his shoulders
much like his origins in the game he is
in fact a member of the black dragon
in the games cabal was too a part of
this organization
and he shows up later on in the film
unlike the games though cabal blames
kaner for his condition
whereas originally it was kintara who
caused it
kana actually saved him which changes up
things quite a lot from what we see here
shang tsung sends in reptile after them
and he even calls him by his name
saizoth which is what talking versions
of the character have referred to
themselves as
reptile looks very similar to his
version from deadly alliance
and he's able to turn invisible much
like in the games
when going head-to-head with the villain
kano rips his heart out
which is too a fatality that the
character has had in several of the
games
kano says kano wins which is similar to
what the announcers say in the series
upon declaring victory for someone
these catch phrases also pop up
throughout the film and kung lao says
flawless victory
which is what would be said if players
defeated another without taking a hit
liu kang also says fatality and there's
also a moment when the toll
tests your might which is a mini game
from the series
kano learns how to shoot lasers from his
eyes and at the end of the film
he gets stabbed in one by sonia blade
whilst the character
never has a false eye and metal play
over his face in the film
i really hope that he survived this
attack and ends up coming back in the
sequel
looking closer to how he does in the
original games
kano also says he's working on a graphic
novel which
might be a nod to the comic series
raiden and kano
interestingly in that the pair were
working together but kano betrayed him
much like how he does in the film from
here the group traveled to raiden's
temple
but along the way they get lost this is
because the gps doesn't work
which might be a nod to the original
movie in which sonia's compass was
rendered useless due to the island being
an anomaly
here they meet liu kang and at one point
he brings up boricho
this was an outworld warrior who teamed
up with the people of earth realm
in order to fight shao khan however
because of his origins he was unable to
fight for earth
and instead spent millennia training
shaolin monks
in the ways of mortal combat in the
temple we see several murals of the
previous winners
and huge shout outs to everyone on our
last video for pointing out that we can
catch the great kung lao
dahlia august goro and xiao khan amongst
these
you also meet kung lao descendant of the
great kung lao
which might be one of the worst slides
of dialogue ever i don't know why
i don't know why it was just absolutely
killing me now i've also just realized
that i've not introduced myself if this
is your first time here then welcome to
the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy that
found an amazing myleena costume in my
mom's underwear draw
and i'd love it if you stuck around here
on the channel we do videos like this
each and every day so make sure you
subscribe
as it would be great to have you as part
of the team we're not we're not doing
any big
fight against our world or anything just
just would be nice to have you around
now the temple has lots of cool things
going on in it
and this place is absolutely packed with
mortal kombat easter eggs
at one point we see the amulet of
shinnok which belonged to the villain
it's one of the most powerful weapons in
mortal kombat law
and could tease at the character coming
down the line we can also catch a blue
steel fan
which is a weapon that is used by katana
weirdly she doesn't show up in this film
but her evil clone mylena does so it is
possible that we may see her in the next
century
liu kang also keeps using the leg sweep
on kano
and i swear this used to annoy me so
much back in the day
no matter what combo i did some idiot
would always just keep sweeping me
all the time and i tell you okay no i
really feel for you just just
kick the crap out the lad now eventually
we get some amazing fights
and kung lao pulls off a fatality that's
very similar his won in the game
however whereas natara is split in half
by her head
in the original it's done by the crotch
kung lao also has his soul sucked out of
him by shang tsung
which itself is a fatality that belonged
to the villain
he says your soul is mine which is also
a catchphrase of the character
say with me your soul is mine
terrible now i'm kind of good at that
they didn't do any shape-shifting with
the villain
as i think it would have been great to
see what happens but hopefully next time
they do more with the character that
shows off his skill set
kung lao's death sucks as he's one of
the best characters
but in the series it's often been used
to push the plot forward
he was first killed in mortal kombat 3
and since then has died more times than
kenny
after escaping into the void the group
decide to go into several fights which
takes them to multiple arenas across the
planet
this includes the pit stage which has
been a mainstay in the series and i tell
you i've uppercutted so many people off
of these throughout the decades
it's actually my spam attack after the
leg sweep one i tell you oh
wait i mean i don't you don't use the
spam attack i said i don't use that
now several fatalities from the game are
brought up here including lukang's
dragon one
which has been something that has
appeared in almost every game
melina is also shot through the abdomen
and we can see her spine through the
wound which
too is similar to one of the fatalities
from the source material
the film culminates with a tease towards
johnny cage who of course
is a big character from the game the
poster is advertising a film called
citizen cage
which was actually name dropped by
johnny during one of his introductions
in the series
we can also see that his belt buckle has
cage written on it
which makes me think that the chest
might have the johnny tattooed from the
games on
which i think would be absolutely
hilarious in a sequel
now we don't know if the sequels are
coming yet but in the meantime
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
movie and if we missed any easter eggs
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
i said thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like this make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check our ending explained
breakdown of the movie which will be
linked on screen right now we've gone
over the film from top to bottom and
discussed what could be happening in a
sequel
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way thank
you for sticking through the video
i've been paul now finish finish him
finish the video i'll see you next time